and I'm friends with Will I Love Will
Will started my career it's one of your
big stories yeah
you don't think I'm a [__] terrified
to tell that Will Smith wanting to [__]
me in the ass you don't think I'm
terrified to tell that [__] story you
don't think I have a slap coming my way
when I see him I have to [__] write
that guy off because if I see him in a
[__] studio and he's walking up I'm
like [__] him dude he's coming to hit me
I didn't realize he don't have a [__]
sense of humor I've been talking about
him wanting to [__] me in the ass for
how long [__] 20 years I mean you
came on the after show and did it with
me dude like the first thing when we'll
when Chris Rock got slapped I go I got
one of those coming yeah I didn't
realize the name of the story was that
Will Smith wanted to [__] man did he
really I don't know the story well I'm
not gonna tell him now
you're making this stop you're making
this worse
he did not want to [__] me in the ass
everyone hey Will if you're listening I
know you did not want to [__] me in the
ass Bert thinks that he did when I heard
the story My [__]
you've heard the rumors so do you did
you get like a Vibe oh sorry all right I
mean because a while ago you are such a
[__] [__] you are you better have
Cheetos you better have Tito's in here
if we're gonna do this story Travis will
you give birth some tinos something to
drink anything to drink for a [__]
grown-up would you just get him actually
I think we have some upstairs go
upstairs and get him a beverage because
the point is that you know before all
this my mother
there was a time when Bert told me a
story okay
and he did at least wonder if maybe sure
Will Smith wanted to do that to him and
also some of his loved ones in his life
told him he definitely did oh if I
remember the story right
yes
I listen you know I consider you a
friend and you know I don't know the
story do you remember when I I was when
I was working the door at the Boston
Comedy Club sure
I can't believe I'm doing this that's a
good idea
[Music]
oh yeah
and if I've heard it if I've heard it I
don't remember it you don't remember
this I don't know if I've heard it I
don't know my memory is losing it's not
fair to Jim yeah I'd love to know this
story
Jim feels out sure ostracized so I was
working the door at the Boston Comedy
Club getting David talkerman comes in
discovers me I do a set on a Thursday
night follow DC Benny I love the small
parts of History
he says he's like hey man we want to do
a deal I work for Overbrook that's Will
Smith's production company I want to do
a development deal I'm working the door
six figure development deal is hanging
over my head and says all you got to do
is you got to meet will if Will likes
you deal set in stone
and I was like great and then like he's
in town next week he's at the Hit
Factory up in up Uptown go to the studio
he's doing his new album Millennium and
uh and meet him if he likes you you're
good now here's the thing you need to
understand is I Love Will Smith I I've
always loved Will Smith I sure I love
him as rapper me and my dad will watch
fresh fresh fresh prince about Bel Air
so and you and your dad ever watched Six
Degrees of Separation no okay we did not
so uh I and and I love hip-hop so I and
I know he so I'm like I'm set up to win
sure yeah so I go up to hit hit Factory
with Barry cats
remember I bought a camera and I was
like hey man can you take a picture of
me and will embarrassing Papa if you
want to work with stars you don't act
like you're not a star and I was like
okay
so they say they take me into this dance
room like a dance studio
two folding chairs facing each other and
they're like we'll be in in a second
mirrors everywhere will walks in and all
I remember is he is a
this is what bothered me about this
whole thing is that's not the guy I know
he is he the thing that when you go that
guy is star
potential will has all of that he has a
hurricane of personality and he gives me
one hug he says one love he sits down
and I'm off to the races I'm like I love
hip-hop I love you I love I love Philly
I grew up my mom's from Philly she's
from Malvern I love black people you're
black I love him I love Tupac what
happens Tupac who killed him do you
listen to juvenile's new album I mean
I'm off to the races and and all I
remember him saying is like I like you
and I'm like good and he goes what are
you doing tonight and I was like huh he
goes let's go to the movies
so you go okay so he's like all right
Planet Hollywood seven o'clock I'll see
you there and I was like
cool so I get out
get in the car and get in a taxi so when
they had the old Nokia brick phones yeah
and I called my dad and he was how did
it go I said great he's like really I
said yeah we're going to the movies my
dad's like on a date
and I go no like just
we're going to the movies and he's like
just you and him and I was like yeah
he's like where I said playing Hollywood
and he goes oh buddy
I'm so sorry I said what he goes this is
one of those Casting Couch things like
what are you talking about he goes
I think he wants to [__] you in the ass
I go what are you talking about Dad and
he goes this is very popular in
Hollywood these guys [__] yes
[__] yes he's like these guys in
Hollywood they get so tired of [__]
that the only thing that turns them on
is the look on a young boy's face when
they [__] him in the ass which is
amazing inside for your dad yeah he's
not like a Hollywood guy absolutely but
he wishes he was what a [__] hell man
something inside of the Hollywood no no
I know what they like
I said are you serious my dad goes Buddy
what's more possible the fact that
you're so talented that after doing
stand-up for six months that the biggest
movie star in the world wants to make a
sitcom about you or that he's gay and he
wants to [__] you in the ass I'm like
I'm getting [__]
that's not supportive I said what do I
do dad do I not show up he goes oh no no
show up show up he goes I could be wrong
he goes look buddy he [__] cash checks
show up by killing my only son go into a
gun fight not knowing what's happening
right so I go all right so I I dress
frumpy again you want to be unattractive
I want to be unattractive I go up to
Planet Hollywood now I'm like the [__]
am I doing a Planet Hollywood was there
a movie theater here that's what I was
thinking like that's not usually people
really let's go to the movies Planet
Hollywood's a restaurant yeah so I go up
to play in Hollywood I go to the front
desk and I goes Will Smith here and
they're like oh yeah in the back and I
was like oh thank God it's a mannequin
of him
I'm come back I'm like no I'm looking
for Will Smith the actor the woman the
local woman's face was like
yeah he's this isn't where celebrities
going to hang out this is Planet
Hollywood like you'll never see a
celebrity here and I said no I'm
supposed to meet Will Smith here to
watch a movie and she's like the [__] do
you yeah she's like yeah no Will Smith
isn't coming here to watch a movie I
said you have a movie theater she goes
no we don't have a [__] movie theater
this is playing in Hollywood and I'm
like all right whatever in my head I'm
like I I got [__] but I'm not at least
I'm not getting [__] in the ass yeah
so I sit down I go do you mind if I wait
for him he's like yeah wait for Will
Smith Robert De Niro's on his way so I
sit in the in the waiting room of Planet
Hollywood the lobby or whatever
all sudden out of a glass door to the
side of me it opens up and a six foot
seven 350 pound black man named Charlie
Mack sticks his head out and he goes
you burp and I'm like yeah and he goes
downstairs and I'm like [__] I'm gonna
have to [__] this guy too this guy's
[__] I hope he starts it and loosens
me up for the right yeah sure so I walk
follow this guy downstairs and I get
downstairs and there are
10 black dudes all in a room maybe this
big curtains velvet curtains around
everything it's an empty room velvet
curtains this big 10 black dudes
standing in silence
and I'm like this is gonna be a long
[__] night I gotta [__] these 10
black dudes Charlie Mac Will Smith I'm
sure he's bringing Jazzy Jeff probably
right yeah so I don't say anything to
anyone I just literally stand I stand
there I don't talk to anyone I just kind
of look down I don't I feel like I'm in
the wrong [__] room yeah
10 minutes goes by and Will Smith shows
up once again a hurricane of personality
and I swear to God on my [__]
children he's with Jazzy Jeff
I swear to God on my children Jazzy
Jeff's with them
and he looks around and goes hey guys
this is Bert and everyone's like all
right and they start walking at me I'm
like okay I'll start sucking their dicks
right I'll suck their dick see if I can
get out of it that way I don't mind
swallowing [__] and [__] me in the ass
gonna make for a long [__] story as I
as as they all walk towards me the
curtains behind me open up I feel it on
my heels and they reveal a private movie
theater behind me
and and Will Smith Goes what do you want
to drink and I was like a Long Island
iced tea and he was like okay he's like
you like shrimp I was like I love shrimp
you just get us the best seats and so I
go okay so I get us the two best seats
in the movie theater right
and we watch a movie we watch uh uh uh
American Pie and a part of me goes is
this a test to find out if I'm funny or
what I laugh at someone like in a TV
show or is it kind of because it's kind
of a horny comedy too yeah is there
something to that yeah well we get done
and he everyone kind of gets up and he
hits me and he's like real private
personal space he goes what'd you think
I said this is great it's a great movie
he was no
what do you think about the room
I go what do you mean
he's like bird you said you were a
hip-hop fan take a look around and I
look around it is all the legends of
hip-hop he had invited them there so I
could meet them because I told him I was
a hip-hop fan right next to me is
[__] bismarckee I go I could have
[__]
[Laughter]
the [__] greatest thing that ever
happened in my life he took me out to
Hollywood he introduced me to all the
networks he taught me how to sell a show
he was the greatest I saw his dick
that's a great story I saw his dicks had
a [__] hog on him is he packing yes
and Jim we go into ABC right and this is
my very first pitch very Jamie Taurus is
super pigeon too we go in and I had to
piss so bad I go into the bathroom to
piss and will walks in with me and he's
going in to give me a peps talk he's
like here's what you need to know about
Hollywood and he starts pissing and it
sounds like a [__] civil rights fire
hose it is so loud it is I hear German
Shepherd's barking
it is the and you know when you hear a
dude's piss you go that's a big deal
there's a giant penis attached to that
look over and I'm like [__] that
guy's got a [__] on him and I can't piss
immediately I can't piss and all I'm
thinking is just piss just piss just
piss but he's giving me the insights of
how to work Hollywood here's what you
need to know and I'm not listening to
any of it but also ironically like you
were worried that he was trying to do
something with you in that movie theater
and you're the one Packer chicken yeah
oh yeah ironically yes yeah honestly
ironically yes is he charismatic in a
room trying to sell a show
yeah
yeah he is he
and I'm look man I know that you're not
supposed to talk good about Will Smith
right now but like
he is the kind of guy that when you see
him interact with people you go how long
did you grow up with that guy and he's
like no I just met him and you're like
what the [__] he has this energy about
him that is so overwhelming it's this is
not this is a bad analogy okay and
because I know I'm gonna be made fun of
but he reminded me a lot of the time of
Godfrey you know God for you can just
Godfrey has that thing about him that
just brings you in Godfrey can literally
walk into a room know nobody and he's
the star in the room it's [__] it's
crazy Godfrey draws focus when he walks
in a room Will Smith draws focus and
here's the other thing about will is he
doesn't need to speak he's like he's one
of the guys that he can listen smile and
be like uh-huh okay and you feel like
he's
you feel like he's uh like giving you
energy to make it better like that was
one thing I was amazed we go into pitch
meetings he would say nothing the one
word he'd say was brilliant it would
take the room down and he and he gives
you like
uh so like we went into NBC and will
knew everyone at NBC and like everyone
was like tell us uh how you been I'm so
proud of you congrats on the movies
you're killing it and then all of a
sudden we realized we're in ourselves a
sitcom about me and I go and they're
like well wait hold on enough about you
tell us about Bert and will goes Bert
tell them your story and I go now this
is a story all about and he starts going
and just gets into it like he's like
[__] with you he's the best with you
he's the [__] best do you think he's
flirting no no no no no no I'm just
going back to that first story